hey it's Peter Brown here with a news
update Microsoft announced yesterday
we'll begin rolling out its reputation
system for the Xbox one later this month
players will now be sorted into three
categories good player needs work and
avoid me when you look at someone's
gamer card you'll be able to see the
reputation at a glance Microsoft program
manager Michael Dunn said that the vast
majority of players do not regularly
receive feedback from others and thus
will stay at the good player reputation
level if a player is getting lots of
reports for being abusive they can drop
to the needs work category they will get
warnings designed to remind players
about their affect on the community
encourage them to have more positive
interactions people who drop to the
lowest reputation category avoid me can
experience penalties such as reduced
matchmaking pairings or even a banned
from twitch broadcasting done went on to
say we designed the algorithm so won't
penalize you for bad reports over a few
weeks of play the system also adjusts
for false reports from people that might
intentionally report someone of greater
skill or for other griefing purposes for
more Xbox one news and updates on the
new reputation system stay tuned to